vous
EEMA de la famille,
nous étions le troupeau avec elle, sachez qu'elle a
inventé la terre abstraite avant le pistolet dans le
ski et le mariage, elle s'occupait du
monde des esprits et communiquait avec nous aussi
vous avez
peur de tout ce qu'on vous demande d'accord,
je suis un acheteur personnel, je déteste ce travail en
fait  Je passe mes journées à faire des conneries
qui ne m'intéressent pas et ça m'empêche
de quoi ça me
rend fou elle vient ici je dois retourner pour
perdre sa maison la moindre chose que mon
frère est mort ici alors on a fait ce serment
celui qui est mort  pour nous qu'est-ce qu'il y a de l'autre
côté fils
mais comment sais-tu si c'est plus un signe
de toi
ton tour
mais tu dois aussi te libérer de
lâcher
après la mort il n'y a rien
il est là